you know diatomaceous earth has been
around for
a long time like millions and millions
of years and what it is it's a powder
made up of fossilized diatoms now what
is a diatom well that is basically algae
or phytoplankton
and over eons this phytoplankton dies
and becomes fossilized and ends up in
the bottom of a lake and the unique
thing about diatomaceous earth is it's
loaded with silicon okay now when
silicon is exposed to oxygen it becomes
silica and silica is really good for
connective tissue
joints
and your bone in fact calcium can't even
help you form bone without silica so to
help the mineralization of bone and to
prevent osteoporosis and osteopenia you
definitely need enough silica silica is
also necessary to make ligaments tendons
cartilage your nails become strong with
enough silica they become brittle
without silica your hair becomes brittle
without silica
your skin loses the strength without
silica and so if your skin is wrinkly or
you have loose skin
you may benefit from silica the strength
of your aorta and your vessels need
silica and so silica could potentially
prevent an aneurysm
silica is also needed to build a strong
trachea and so there's different types
of collagen and silica stimulates type 1
collagen and diatomaceous earth has some
other interesting benefits
it can help you potentially get rid of
parasites and worms and pathogens and
even e coli because it helps to scrub
and sweep away these microbes in your
intestinal tract and the third thing
that it can help you with is binding
with aluminum now normally diatomaceous
earth has aluminum
in its structure but it's very tightly
bound to silica and even just like
different types of clay or rocks like
quartz for example has aluminum in it
that's very very tightly bound but when
you take diatomaceous earth this
aluminum is not going to leach out in
your body in fact it's going to bind
aluminum and it has a strong affinity
for it's going to pull it in and bind to
it and remove it from the body so if
you're going to take diatomaceous earth
whether you're going to do a detox
program or you're going to strengthen
something in your body start off with
one teaspoon per day in a glass of water
okay
and then over the next three days maybe
you increase it to two teaspoons per day
it's important to take it on an empty
stomach because you need strong stomach
acids to
absorb this trace mineral and so a lot
of people don't have a very very strong
acidic stomach and so they have a very
difficult time extracting the silica
from this diatomaceous earth so to
improve the absorption it might be smart
to add apple cider vinegar to that water
or take a few butane hydrochloride
little tablets when you're taking this
but this hydrochloric acid helps you
convert the silica into an a more
absorbable form called
orthosolicic
acid now if you're just trying to build
up this connective tissue
maybe you just want to get this as a
supplement but
taking diatomaceous earth has some other
great benefits as well like i said now
since we're on the topic of connective
tissue i think you should really watch
this video right here